[Musique]
cette semaine dans les salles de
l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois nous vous proposons le
film d'animation en avant en sortie
nationale et à partir de 6 ans qui vous
raconte l'histoire de deux jeunes frères
elf qui cherche à découvrir un monde
meilleur dans leur monde imaginaire
nous vous proposons également le très
attendu dernier clint eastwood le cas de
richard jewel et les images vagabonde en
partenariat avec l'association
contrechamp un festival qui met l'accent
sur les femmes rebelles avec jackie
brown et human at war ce lundi est
également les invisibles et thelma et
louise
pendant deux semaines les deux lundi
prochain nous aurons également rebelles
pour le jeune public
enfin nous vous invitons à venir la
semaine prochaine pour l'avant-première
de pinocchio
retrouvez toutes ces informations sur le
site des clayes-sous-bois et à très
bientôt à l'espace philippe noiret
[Musique]